jean-claude yonkers presentation of his
2015 work program was as he wants his
new commission to be minimalist and to
the point starting with the big lesson
of 2014 is a real impression upon da la
combined electoral Calissa triopia
bullet of work and nevada carnival
including he declared the fight against
tax evasion and the key priority LaGrant
priority sell convey pollute gravatt 02
des el amor estas y entre and a few
minutes later over to his deputy to give
the details advancing the digital single
market migration deeper economic and
monetary union and cuts to laws that are
blocked obsolete or in the Commission's
view ineffective it is time to clear the
decks so that time and energy can be
invested in those proposals that will
have the biggest impact on jobs and
growth and which have a good prospect of
being adopted in the near future in all
83 of 452 laws to be rewritten changed
or amended including an energy tax waste
management and air quality they're part
of what's coming to be known as a kill
list em eps have different reactions we
are welcoming change however we have
been through this exercise so the
implementation of this commission work
program is the key mi grupo tiene
prioridades NOS conocen perfectamente
redo Cleon del desempleo especialmente
entre los colinas conservatives outside
the EPP were broadly welcoming so long
as legislation asks a crucial question
does it make it easier or harder for
European businesses to thrive this means
regulating only where there is a strong
and well tested case but some liberals
felt the kill list is nothing more than
a free pass to member states to block
legislation today is it a mantra safka
see font of secular she's more long da
opt really twerk away gets golf a fee up
stack it be on till click there was
however scorned from the Greens who
watched air quality and waste management
knocked off for the time being one of
the new commissions green credentials
they ask DNA kingdom at once he lets the
legislature he FF worked omniverse NYADA
see an animal attention on
martes royal back from red energy and
chemical ETO back to Tom about da vert
yet snore and stuff gazetted the issue
is to be voted on in Parliament during
the first plenary session of 2015